[Music]
as we all know by now it can be scary to
be a black person in america
there is a constant fear of police
violence whether you're breaking the law
or not
it can make you look over your shoulder
when you're going for a jog
shopping and especially using your phone
that's why we here at the amber ruffin
show have teamed up with the folks at
apple
to bring you an exciting new product the
iphone black the iphone black
it's an iphone for black people there's
no way a cop will
ever mistake these phones for guns the
iphone black comes in three different
shapes
little dog bouquet of flowers and white
baby
hello who's there safety
and unlike a regular iphone that just
had a software update
the iphone black works perfectly take a
look
hey honey i just finished my run i'll be
home soon
hey what do you got there
is that a frenchie
it is so
i'm trying this new recipe tonight and
that's not allowed
to have peonies that perfect this time
of year
yeah i think the interview went pretty
well yeah
uh we have a kidnapping in progress
[Music]
okay maybe we haven't worked out all the
kinks yet
police violence in america is at an
all-time high and
the best way to stop it short of
changing police guidelines holding them
accountable redirecting police funds to
agencies more equipped to deal with
social services
and abolishing police altogether is with
the iphone black
the iphone black for when you want to
make a phone call
and live
[Music]
you